under no circumstances should
Republicans vote to cut a single penny
from Medicare or Social Security as we
all apparently agree
Social Security Medicare is off the off
the books now you know you're in deep
deep trouble when Joe Biden and Donald
Trump agree on anything and that's
especially true when it comes to
insisting that nobody ever anywhere cut
a single penny from Social Security the
nation's income program for people over
65. here are three reasons why Social
Security should be scrapped completely
and replaced with a plan that will help
the truly needy without impoverishing
everyone else first social security is
unsustainable created in 1935 Social
Security is paid for by a 12.4 percent
payroll tax on income up to a hundred
and sixty thousand two hundred dollars
supporters pretend that Social Security
is like a retirement plan where your
specific contributions build value over
time but the system is a Ponzi scheme in
which current beneficiaries are paid out
of new money coming into the system the
problem is that when the program started
paying out benefits in 1940 there were
160 workers per retiree so a surplus
built up today there are just 2.8
workers per retiree in a decade there
won't be enough money coming into the
system to cover the current level of
benefits and by law benefits will need
to be cut by about 20 percent or payroll
taxes will need to be jacked up even
more than they already are reason 2
Social Security is unfair the payroll
tax hits younger poorer workers harder
than older wealthier workers a minimum
wage worker might pay virtually nothing
in federal taxes but will still be
forced to forego 12.4 percent of his or
her compensation and it's a bad deal
according to a 2 2016 tax Foundation
study a worker retiring after making
average wages could expect an annual
payout from Social Security of about 20
grand if that person had instead put
just 10 percent of their annual earnings
into a conservative Ira they could
expect an annual retirement income of
almost three times more oh and don't
think the government actually owes you
anything when you retire regardless of
what you paid in in 1960 the Supreme
Court ruled in Fleming V Nester that
there is no contractual right to receive
Social Security benefits Reason 3 Social
Security is unnecessary when Social
Security was passed during the Great
Depression old age and poverty went hand
in hand now the median net worth of
households headed by someone over 65 is
more than double that of households
headed by someone half their age to be
fair part of that's because of Social
Security and Medicare but it's mostly
because people are living and working
longer and growing more wealth so that
old age programs are less and less
important to financial stability and
well-being there's no reason to pay out
universal benefits to millionaires like
Joe Biden and billionaires like Donald
Trump rather than job burning about
saving Social Security politicians and
voters should be demanding that we wind
it down as quickly as possible let
people within a decade or so of
retirement get benefits but reduce and
eliminate payroll taxes for the rest of
us so we have more money to fund our own
retirements the federal government can
and should continue to help older
Americans indeed Americans of any age
who need assistance with food housing
and health care but that doesn't require
forcing all of us to pay into a system
that is increasingly unsustainable
unfair and unnecessary
foreign
[Music]